-It's good to be here on a --
on a happy day.
-Yeah. The news -- The news
felt different last night.
-I -- I -- I slept.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-It was so weird.
And all people
had to do was vote.
-Yeah.
-'Cause this whole time,
we've been like,
"How does this end?"
And then people just voted.
We're like, "Oh, then these
people all just go away."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Like, if everyone votes,
it all goes away.
-[ Laughing ]
It's really nice.
-'Cause I was hoping
on the pee tape.
That was my thing.
I was like, is this pee tape --
You know, there's a rumor.
We don't know if it's real.
-Yeah.
-"There's a pee tape.
Someone's getting peed on
or peeing on,
and we don't know what it is."
Probably doesn't exist,
but we want it to.
-Right.
-'Cause then it goes away.
No one loses their job.
-Yeah.
-No one loses their healthcare.
Just a little pee-pee.
-Yeah.
-Just a little pee-pee.
-But if there is one
and Trump goes away,
who becomes the president?
-Yeah, Pence.
-That's right.
So we need another tape.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
See, I think the problem is --
I think you're in trouble
after the first one.
'Cause I think -- I don't think
there's a tape on Mike Pence.
-[ Laughs ]
-You know?
I think the worst tape
is, like, probably just him
sitting in an empty room,
staring at a brick wall.
[ Laughter ]
-He thinks he's so sexy,
he can't be alone in a room
with a woman.
-Yeah, exactly.
-And I always wondered, "Does
he think he's gonna attack her
or she's gonna attack him?"
-Yeah.
Also, it's at a restaurant,
so there would be waiters
there to stop it.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, he won't even go
to a restaurant with staff.
-Really?
-Yeah, I don't think
he'll have meals with women.
I don't know.
-I think what we need
is a tape that's
a Russian hooker
peeing on, like, 40 Republicans
so we finally get Bernie Sanders
to be the president of the
United States of America.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I could see that.
-It's gonna take some work.
-It's gonna take some work
and a lot of water.
-Yeah.
-And what is your take?
Obviously,
you work in this industry.
-Yes.
-Because it's been very easy
to criticize
what's happening in D.C.
-Hollywood.
-Yes.
-Even New York show business
under the microscope right now
for some terrible behavior.
-That's right.
-What is your take
on the sexual harassment?
-You know, I don't know.
'Cause my instinct
is always to say the thing
they say, "Don't say,"
which, you know, it concerns me,
you know, as a father
of two daughters.
It concerns me.
But you shouldn't
have to have daughters
to get that it's disgusting.
-Yeah.
-Right?
You should be able to say,
"As the owner of a bird,
I'm disgusted."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, right, yeah.
-Like, everybody
should be disgusted.
-Yeah.
-It's horrible!
It's like women always knew
men were disgusting.
And now men are going,
"I guess we are disgusting."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Like, we didn't know
how terrible that we were.
And it's so easy
to not be a sexual harasser.
You just literally do nothing.
-Yeah.
-You do nothing, and you're
like, "He's a great guy."
And you did, like,
absolutely nothing.
-What about --
The one that was
so hard for me
because it was somebody
I had a great amount of respect
for, Senator Al Franken.
-Yeah.
-But that photo
was a very difficult photo
to look at.
He took that picture.
-Yeah.
-I understand, you know,
his defense of it was a joke.
But it certainly was
a very hard thing to look at.
What is your take
on photos like that?
-Well, it's concerning,
because I was like,
"What photos
have I taken in my life?"
You know?
-Yeah.
-Do you ever think that?
Do you do the Rolodex,
and you just go like,
"What have I done?"
And so I went through
all my photos.
I went through 35,000 photos,
honestly, and scrolled to see,
like, "What do I have
on the Cloud
that someone will find one day
that will end me?"
-And how many of the 35,000
were career-enders?
-There were literally hundreds
of me pretending to blow guys.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-But we were all laughing.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-And I think it's okay.
But, yeah,
I think we're all learning.
-Yeah.
-We're all learning that men
do not get it at all
how awful they are.
Like all this masturbating --
Who knew that masturbation
was so popular
that everyone, like, has to
masturbate in front of people.
I always thought that
the best part of masturbation
was that you were alone...
-Yeah.
-...and no one
was judging you, right?
-Yeah.
-Isn't that why we like it?
That no one is there to go,
"What's the matter with you?"
-I agree.
[ Laughter ]
I fully agree.
-And you need someone there.
It's also, like, an enormous
lack of imagination.
-Yeah, that's the whole point.
Well, I feel like, in general,
we all have worse imaginations
than we did 30 years ago.
-Well, we have none.
-Yeah.
-People doing it on the phone,
like, doing it on the phone
while the other person doesn't
know that you're doing it.
Let me just say this --
if you hear me making
a weird noise on the phone,
I'm not masturbating.
But 50/50, I'm pooping.
-Oh, okay.
-50/50.
[ Laughter ]
-That's time management.
-That's fine.
-Yeah, and that's decent.
-You're hard
to get on the phone.
-Yeah exactly.
-That's two birds
with one stone.
-And that's something
everyone does.
There's even a book about it,
I'm pretty sure.
-There is?
-Yeah.
I want to talk about
your special.
Well, you come back to stand-up.
-Yes.
-It's been years
you've been away from it.
When you were first
starting out,
you were doing it
with a lot of people
who became
very successful at it.
This is a photo of you
and Jim Carrey back in the day.
This is one of the photos
that's not a career-ender.
That is a terrifying Jim Carrey.
[ Laughter ]
-This is why I stopped doing
stand-up comedy as a young man.
Because I clearly
didn't have the energy
and focus that Jim had.
-Yeah.
-Like, look at the photo --
this is him between shows.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-This is his everyday energy.
Look at me -- I'm hugging
the pillow, just terrified.
-You used it
between shows to sleep.
-Exactly, yeah.
-You've obviously
been a long lover of stand-up
and a long supporter
of people who are starting out
and younger comedians.
Pete Holmes,
his show, "Crashing,"
he's been doing it
a long time now,
but this is a show about
when he was first starting out.
-Yes, it's based on his life
a little bit, fictionalized,
and it's on HBO.
We have our second season
coming back January 14th.
And it's about
this religious man
who wants to be a comedian
in the dirty cesspool
that is New York.
-We have a clip
from season two, right?
-This is a clip.
He just talked to Penn Jillette
who convinced him
that maybe God doesn't exist.
And he's very confused,
and then he bumps
into Doug Benson afterwards.
-All right, let's take a look.
-How could everything
be nothing?
-Because we aren't --
-It's everything.
-But do you know?
-About everything?
-What if it was Zeus?
What if it was this one
and now he's mad,
and now you die,
and chances are --
-Who's Zeus?
-That's my point -- Who's God?
Who is God?
Do you know?
-Zeus?
-What if you've been praying
to Jesus, and it was Zeus?
-Jezeus.
[ Laughter ]
-Judd Apatow, everybody!